alors voir si vous l'êtes vialli vous
répondez car en même temps tu as sur
twitter hashtag jalousie tmp vous mettez
votre réponse dit par jalousie a déjà
fouillé dans le portable de son conjoint
alors alors oui vous le be bop ça marche
aussi
elle a vu l'historique sur minitel
oui oui vous alors les stades pas
forcément drôle mais les vrais j'ai
jamais raconter parce que je suis fâché
que la personne
bah oui non plus là on ne veut pas leur
a coûté oui oui bon je m'en fous comme
ça sert tout de famille mais je m'en
fous alesi est en fait j'avais un copain
à l'époque avait au moins un nom qu'on
sortait ensemble et je voulais bien que
ça a commencé un peu textoter tout que
je vous donne quand soir sa texture toc
sam le téléphone comme ça le téléphone
retourner et un soir j'ai pris le
téléphone j'ai après avoir su le code
j'ai pris le téléphone par un quai
devant le banc et j'ai regardé mon
téléphone et j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
photos de sexes qui arrivait et fizi
saisies multiples visages un certain
nombre de saisies à certains de zizi et
dérision faut comprendre d'autres
dépositions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y avait marqué jus au dessus je sais pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la vélodyssée toi tu veux juste non dans
les prénoms voyez juste parce que c'est
fait et je vois les izik qui passe 26
comités dans le bain puis me parle pas
peut-être qu'il prenait des vidéos de
deux paysages et la dernière photo il
m'avait dit si le mans 11 la 11e photo
jure que c'est vrai je clique dessus on
voit le visage
cyril
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est qui et je vous jure que
c'est vrai dana photos et je ferai en
fait c'est mon cousin
non non mais elle savait pas qu'il était
gay by ce n'est pas sympa la famille et
on avait été deux fois en famille et mon
cousin
donc depuis il s'est tapé mon copain et
vous êtes toujours cousin avec lui mais
question très intéressante oui
non mais c'est vrai à toutes ces
questions de 6 et magazine magazine où
il combat comment tu a reconnu mais
hésite on présente dans la tête mais
autos la 11e vélo tout mais jamais vu
mon cousin nu ah oui c'est jacques roy
quand tu sois des repas de famille salut
mais c'est la maman j'ai quand même avec
son famille tranquille à wall non mais
attends et janry les textos évidemment
lui c'est pareil j'en avais plein de
textos riz les maris des textos pour
s'excuser c'est calme ou cousins
germains arrive assez foncée jamais
reparlé depuis donc s'ils regardent la
télévision ce soir
hashtag que ça ne passe pas donc toi tu
fous dans le portable d'un diabète je
suis sûr non jamais j'ai jamais fait ça
de ma vie
ah ouais alors tu sors avec des meufs
sans portable jamais trouver le code en
fait savoir en fait je déteste ça
kouassi aka son envie de voir fouiller
dans les téléphones des gens tous âges
étaient très bien quand on cherche être
mais tu veux je te dis je déteste qu'on
me le fasse mal est fait et aimerait je
te fasse ça
[Rires]
pour toi moi je vais te faire ou ce
n'est pas je pense que tu peux pas
empêcher une femme de fouiller dans le
téléphone par exemple un terme à quatre
années quand sa femme elle consomme le
rcam sur la tête de ma mère c'est mieux
que comme jamais permis qui s'appelle
être pas mort d'homme il en mode chaude
[Rires]
oui il faut savoir qu'un homme sait que
aurore sa femme à connecter son portable
au four pour eux c'est vrai mais sur le
fond non mais si fade away
d'ailleurs elle voit pas chez moi mais
la région mais comme ça elle et se
connecte au four et toute la journée
devant alors attention qu'ils portent
jalousie c'est déjà danger d'un ex ou
d'une ex toi ouais c'est parce que votre
femme l'ex non moi j'ai fait un truc
horrible
vous avez fait pipi un peu glissé mais
mais mais pas seulement au rck s'arrêter
là vous êtes comme ils s'installaient
dans monte dans ma dans mon appartement
que on les perd un peu en séparation je
savais qu'il allait bien à votre cas
wade et buvait de la vodka un peu en
bresse à la même table à bisons gros
avantage de cette vodka si on fait pipi
dedans pas trop ça reste jaune dont jeu
tous les jours je vais un petit pipi
dedans donc tous les jours il a bu
largement je pense qu on urine et après
et le sommet alors il paraît qu'il a
beaucoup m'ont dit oui alors mon plus
grand kiff c'est une chose très remonté
après je montais dans la bande donc dans
mon ex chambre et donc dans mon
excellent demain et ce qui me rendait
fou je voyais ce [ __ ] de brosses à
dents et à chaque fois que je pourrais
jouer ce brosse à dents je la prenais un
an et je me brosse est intégralement la
nuit non non non non aux larmes étaient
tous là nue non armes étaient non et oui
très bons centres et le supra nu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
orange est déjà rangée d'arbres du next
one way je me suis déjà mangé et staff
et je sais pas si je peux dire c'est pot
qui dirige voilà tu le dis pas ici tu
vas pas garçon ça dommage il a dû que tu
peux te grèce j'ai déjà envoyé une ex
dans un autre pays 1 me rejoindre alors
que j'étais pas là c'est sûr qui surtout
ouais j'ai jamais dans de sueur qui
n'ont pas assez mais riche en turquie et
donc à taper elle tenu à l'eau moi je
suis inquiet mais non oui mais qu'est ce
que je fais je reprends l'avion pour
istanbul nord-ouest avait tué dix a pris
non après je lui ai dit ouais je lui ai
dit que j'étais pas pourquoi pourquoi
t'as fait ça je le dis parce que qu'est
ce qu'elle avait fait la victime et
chante vous avez donc fait de la peine
non mais en fait je suis très très très
très rancunier c'est à dire que c'est un
petit truc moi je pars aussi retenu
wayne il n'a pas l'air comme ça dit une
alerte aux 12e et mon père je voulais
rien du tout elle avait trompé nous
avons peu de soutien à la relève et pour
se venger et envoyer des eyzies turcs
ont fait par contre pour se voir que
l'on a envoyé un dvd de votre
[Rires]
là c'est sûr ça aurait été beaucoup plus
écrire d'abondance bouthinon mère était
avec les vengeances l'apady vie coûte
éméché il a bien eu des axes quant aux
je suis l'animateur c'est l'opposé fish
et que je pose une question qu'est-ce
qui se passe eh ben vous répondre aux
questions je ne suis pas là pour ça vous
êtes qui est recyclé de vous je ne
connais pas madame qui par jalousie a
déjà balancé une personne que son
conjoint avait un amant bien compris la
question oui alors jean-luc de koh lanta
mois moi j'ai pas balancer directement
je dédie à la fille parce que j'étais
obligé j'étais en train de faire des
livraisons au quartier de la bourse et
les restaurants de sushis non mais il ya
un club libertin juste à côté et je suis
en train de rentrer dans le car de
bourse ont retenu deux
j'adore j'adore il a fait comme ça club
lubasa côté de la bourse
ça c'est où le prélude houleux de plus
de ça depuis deux à montparnasse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a dit oui alors oui ouais donc je
vois je vois cette fille sortir ce je
regarde qui sort je suis curieux et je
la vois sortir je suis dit c'est pas
vrai je tape sur le volant gt gt
veinards 15 ans le poste que je le
connais depuis 15 ans et j'étais obligée
avec le temps je voulais pas lui dire
quand je les vois surtout liée à la
liberté non moi je livrais les sushis
les restaurants de sushis j'aimerais des
boissons aux grandes sushis et elle a
des sorties du club libertin je vais le
dilemme de dire est ce que je lui dis du
train de faire les travaux dans la
maison des gamins y est en train de
casser des cloisons faire une vie de
christina merkel gérard leila il a
appelé au budget tabac fait les bons
choix que des maquis dis lui toi parce
que moi je vais être obligé de me dire
avec le tas c'est jean elle est alors
elle l'a dit avec l'otan à lui à 10 sont
séparés mais c'est pas possible qu à l
éclosion à fait tort juillet dans sa
culotte c'est pas possible c'est ça tout
problème c'est qu'après tu parles comme
ça photo canon
il livre un truc après qui par jalousie
a déjà piqué le copain ou la copine de m
non ce n'est pas sale nom mais elle est
là c'est vrai et sincère vous si jamais
vous mais vous non mais raymond hahn hon
mais je viens de m'apercevoir temps fait
ma dernière histoire d'amour y avait pas
le portable encore non non non à wuhan
et au téléphone elle est au téléphone à
touches non mais on pouvait pas savoir
beaucoup en fouiller dans les poches
quoi s'était pas fait un bon piont
déplacer avec un pigeon voyageur
quand votre dernière je me souviens très
bien mais pas de téléphone
trente ans après jésus christ
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste avant ou après les d'inès ça
ne fait pas si elle est reconnue non
mais c'était il ya 25 ans à peu près
c'est un col ouais j'en mets en quelle
année j'ai jamais vu un mec avec un
portable chez moi que 16 ans
ouais si vous faites mais en revanche on
faisait des coiffes et moi j'ai quitté
j'écoutais qui va être qu'un parce que
j'étais j'étais jalouse en fait il était
à bout de forces qui ont d'ailleurs été
c'était un peu le jean-michel mais
j'étais avec un peu le jean michel maire
de l'époque donc je vous dis ça y est
c'était alors coco n'est pas reconnu
pour écoutez moi bien